هذا الكنز الوطني
الصيني معرض للخطر أكثر من
الباندا ، موطن الغابات المغطاة بالأشنة ،
والمعروف باسم الرجال
المتوحشين للجبال ، تقاتل قرود يونان الذهبية أو القرود
ذات الأنف الأفطس
من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة في
الغابات الشاهقة في جنوب غرب
الصين.  تقول مجموعات الحفاظ على الطبيعة
والحماية البشرية ، إنهم لا يزالون يتشبثون بالحياة العزيزة
لي ،
لم يتبق لي سوى بضعة آلاف في البرية
بالنسبة لي ،
حيث يُقتل ما يقرب من 100 قرد على يد الصيادين
سنويًا في المنطقة وفقًا
لمحافظة الطبيعة
[الموسيقى]
ولكن كجزء من  حملة مراقبة الغابات
shuhao
تدرب القرويين المحليين للقيام بدوريات
في موطن القرد
والبحث عن مصائد الأسلاك القديمة
[موسيقى]
قام فريقه بتركيب أكثر من 100
كاميرا تعمل بالأشعة تحت الحمراء في الغابة لمراقبة
القرود
وبعض جيرانهم الفضوليين
مثل الباندا الحمراء
والدب الأسود الآسيوي
والمارتين ذو الحلق الأصفر الذي
يحمي التنوع البيولوجي
المذهل لهذه المنطقة
هو هدف الحفاظ على الطبيعة
الذي يعمل مع  مع القرويين المحليين
على مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الوكالات الحكومية والشركاء الآخرين
في عام 2019 ، أنشأ تحالف الحفظ هذا
شبكة حماية
للقرود
تمتد عبر ما يقرب من 2700 ميل مربع ،
ويشمل عملهم دعم
المجتمعات المحلية لخلق
سبل عيش بديلة للصيد وقطع الأشجار
مثل بيع المصنوعات اليدوية
وتدريبهم على مراقبة الغابات
[الموسيقى]
لضمان بقاء القرد
للأجيال القادمة في الميزان
بالنسبة لجميع سكان المنطقة ،
نحتاج إلى النظر في تنمية
المنطقة المحلية
والمجتمع ولكن في الوقت نفسه
نحتاج إلى التفكير
الحفاظ على القرود
ونأمل أن نتمكن من التأكد من أن
الناس والقرد يمكنهم السعي في
نفس الوقت
لإثبات أن المثل الذي يتطلبه الأمر هو أن
القرود الذهبية في القرية
تتزايد أخيرًا ، كما يقول لي بونغ ، كما يقول لي بونغ ، كما يقول لي بونغ ،
إن
منطقة لورين شان تضم الآن حوالي 300
القرود الذهبية
والعدد الإجمالي عبر يين مان
والتبت هو  حوالي 3000.
آمل أن يزداد العدد أه
أكثر في المستقبل ،
هذا القرد مثل النوع الرائد
في المنطقة
وهو واحد من النوع الوحيد من الحيوانات التي تعيش
في هذا الموقف العالي ،
لذا فإن وجود هذا النوع هو نوع
من الأهمية والحاسمة بالنسبة  العالم كله